hello everyone welcome to some sub a
channel on how to survive maybe even
thrive in the online jungle and me
i'm lucas i have absolutely nothing to
hide a clean slate and open book no
drunken texts cringy teenage myspace
updates and certainly no large-scale
dogecoin laundering operations do you
believe that
no well of course like all of you i have
things that i wouldn't like to advertise
to the world
my question is then why do government
officials internet giants try to
convince us that we don't have any dirty
laundry to hide
let's figure it
i'm going fully transparent
[Music]
[Music]
initially the phrase if you have nothing
to hide you have nothing to worry about
became the motto of the world's largest
cctv system
it all began when the first street
cameras appeared in london in the 1960s
the capital was preparing for the state
reception of the thai royal family and
with the help of cameras the police
monitored the crowds in trafalgar square
today there are some 620 000 cameras
operating in london and every resident
of london gets captured by these cameras
up to 300 times a day
[Music]
the maintenance of this system cost the
city over 2 billion pounds a year
cameras have become a familiar thing on
the streets of all major cities
let me share some cool resources with
you guys do you know how many cameras
are watching you every day
there are several websites on the
internet showing the density of cctv
cameras in the cities around the world
there are 20 times more of them in
london than in new york and 70 times
more cameras than in the city of rome
the effectiveness of cctv cannot be
disputed but the trouble is the same
arguments
you have nothing to fear if you have
nothing to hide
it has been used in the discussion of
your digital freedoms let's explore a
little bit more about how the digital
space fundamentally differs from the
streets of london
[Music]
the most obvious thing is that the
amount of information gathered about
your actions in the case of video
surveillance systems reality lags behind
hollywood
modern systems cannot identify all the
individual faces in a crowd
within
a certain probability these systems can
notice a passer-by from a small list of
wanted criminals and then this
information can be provided to the
authorities
however there is simply not enough
computing resources to process everyone
in public
in addition for accurate identification
the camera must be located
at about the face level of the person
and approximately at the level of their
eyes
not a simple task when we are talking
about hundreds of thousands of cameras
such conditions could be provided
usually at the entrance of business
centers or at atms but certainly not
everywhere on the streets of a city
so let's jump back a bit to how cameras
help ensure public safety in the case of
an investigation of a crime that has
occurred detectives will review the
recordings from the camera near the
scene of the crime
they start from where the incident
occurred and then track back to where
the criminal came from and where the
criminal disappeared to
moreover it will only be possible to do
this for just a couple of days you see
no city video surveillance system stores
footage older than a couple months by
default
but
monetary purchases are a little bit
easier to track with the help of your
bank
payment data is generally stored for
years it's easy to process and analyze
and it is uniquely associated with your
person
just a couple of requests about the
movement of money in your account will
allow someone to identify your favorite
store get an idea of your typical
expenses and even highlight any unusual
purchases anomalies in your expenses
reveal important and specific
information about you wow what a geek
they spent 69.95 on a wonder mop
that's me
for example if you regularly start
paying for breakfast at a cafe next to
an oncological clinic it is easy to
conclude that either you have got a new
job there you're stalking a nurse or
unfortunately have a very dangerous
disease
payments from a new employer or an
increase in purchases at a pharmacy
supply store will easily confirm if
these predictions are true do not rush
to use cash instead it's not going to
save you your mobile operator already
has detailed information about your
movements even now the police often use
such data to establish where a suspect
was at the time of a crime of course
this is only indirect evidence but a
further problem is that the positioning
data of your phone isn't just used by
law enforcement agencies today state
agencies and companies want to store as
much information as they can
get about us online and offline
they want to have the possibility to
track our lives and they want to store
them for all time if you like to run in
the morning you've probably heard about
the strava app it helps monitor training
intensity it maps out the root of your
workout and allows you to share that
with other users of the application in
november 2018 nathan roosa a true blue
australian cyber security researcher
concluded that this fitness tracker
could pose a serious threat to the lives
of american soldiers in syria
among the 13 billion records out of the
system he singled out the tracks that
gave out the position of military bases
in the middle east had terrorist
organizations had access to this data
well
they could have easily set up ambushes
or attacks during captain america's
morning jog
strava's security policy was promptly
changed and thankfully captain america
is still with us today
but this is just one of a hundred
similar examples we highlighted this a
ton on our channel here and i will
repeat it again and again in the digital
world we leave more traces than in our
ordinary lives data privacy is dead
why because this millennial is the
millennium of transparency
[Music]
to create a system that finds motorists
for speeding and collects a fee for
entering the centre of london
programmers had to teach computers to
distinguish between different card
numbers
but this task is much easier than face
recognition even the most advanced
facial systems can sometimes be deceived
by using particular hairstyles and
makeup which are aimed at disorientating
algorithms
perhaps in the coming years we will see
an increase in outlandish fashion
correlating with an increase in civil
disobedience
[Music]
if you're going to burn down the
capitalist system you may as well do it
in style while thwarting facial
recognition at the same time
why not right
now imagine the government wants to
force you to wear unique numbers on your
clothes
perhaps even a qr arm band
these numbers would allow street cameras
to track your movements more accurately
and thus protect you from criminals
you would agree wouldn't you if you've
got nothing to hide why worry about it
large internet companies already act
this way in fact a unique identifier is
assigned not to you personally but to
your digital double and for some reason
it doesn't really seem to bother people
in addition we are yet to touch on
another important point
remember that surveillance cameras are
installed only in public places
they do not look into your windows they
do not spy on you in your apartment
therefore even police officers wouldn't
be able to assess your beyonce contacts
in the shower but the camera of your
smartphone can and does regularly see
some things that aren't intended for
prying eyes
and these photos and videos can first
get onto the cloud storage and from
there they can end up in the wrong hands
of course there is nothing criminal in
terribly framed pictures let alone more
provocative selfies you take but i doubt
you want all of your colleagues and
business partners to see them and it
turns out there is also something to
hide here although you're not doing
anything particularly illegal i just
want you to look at some photos tell me
what you think
this is an absolutely real threat
remember september 1st 2014 this day has
entered the history books of
cybersecurity as celebgate when 200
private photos of celebrities appeared
on 4chan and reddit at the same time
perhaps you remember that hackers had
entered into the icloud of accounts for
rihanna kirsten dunst jennifer lawrence
and released dozens and dozens of their
private photos the hacker was caught and
ryan collins received an 18-month
service in prison but can this
compensate for the blow to the
reputation and privacy of the victims
and yet there are still more
controversial situations just imagine
that the authorities are interested in
you because six months ago you spent
several hours reading articles about the
production of methamphetamine online now
this information has remained with
google and now you're under
investigation of course you think it
will be easy to prove that you just
wanted to check out if breaking bad was
authentic and of course you had no real
intention of actually setting up a
walter white style business at all you
probably don't even remember what you
read then but search engines certainly
will remember gross fat butthole dick
poop is that what kids are into these
days
are your parents home finally you may
really have nothing to hide you have
nothing to worry about a squeaky clean
individual congratulations
at least according to the laws of the
country in which you live
but your law abidance in britain or the
usa may be interpreted quite differently
in other countries for example if you
were in the united arab emirates a
couple of years ago your child's
smartphone could have caused you some
serious problems
you see in this country there are strict
bans on gambling and some kinds of
electronic games in particular for this
example the mobile game roblox was
banned in 2018. it may never have
occurred to you but if your child had
this app on their phone you would be
breaking the law
similarly your digital footprint left
when releasing troves of us military
secrets online could i don't know land
you in the uk prison facing extradition
charges to the states a scary jungle we
are now navigating it's obvious when you
travel to another country but
accidentally crossing the border in a
virtual space is all too easy let's take
one more example of how complicated this
can be imagine that you are gay and you
decide to flirt a little online with an
unknown man only texts no videos no
pictures just letters and emojis do you
realize that such correspondence could
cause the imprisonment of the person
you're speaking to meanwhile in morocco
tunisia afghanistan and 70 other
countries same-sex relationships are a
criminal offence so
even if you have nothing to hide
insufficiently protecting your
information can play a fatal role in the
fate of other people drawing an analogy
with cctv imagine now that we have
cameras from the taliban north korea or
saudi arabia hanging on the streets of
london or new york and other countries
are watching you through the lens of
their own laws
[Music]
we took it for granted at the beginning
of this video but are ordinary cctv
cameras even effective in their original
role
you see when they were installed in
britain all that time ago the government
promised that they would actually help
reducing the crime rate and in fact if
you look at these figures the number of
cameras does not correlate at all with
the number of crimes committed they do
not prevent new cases but only help to
deal with crimes that have already
happened knowing about the cameras the
criminal will try to hide their face and
remember that bank robbers began to use
masks long before cameras started
appearing on our streets and yet this
year a billionth surveillance camera is
going to be appearing on the planet
happy birthday
to
you
happy birthday
[Music]
why do many of us casually claim that we
have nothing to hide perhaps viewers of
our channel are savvy enough to see
through this
but we all know people who are quite
naive and do believe it this is just a
defense mechanism people consider such
openness to be protection a strategic
advantage in our relation with authority
we are trying to negotiate the system in
advance to show our trustworthiness that
we are law abiding
but often we don't quite realize how
vulnerable our position can become due
to the ever-shifting nature of data
privacy and digital boundaries many
underestimate the importance of the
information they own while we often
appreciate the risk of a stolen bank
card or keys to your house
often we don't even notice the danger
posed to our digital identities privacy
is about power it's about how much power
the government should have to
explore
uh the deepest parts of our lives how
much information should the government
have what should the government be able
to do with that information
sometimes we don't distinguish well
between the boundaries of our personal
lives and other people's secrets that
you share a photo from your birthday
party on instagram this is your holiday
your party your guests but of course
each of them can have their own secrets
their own private lives for example to
congratulate you one of your friends
lied about his plans to their boss and
an innocent post of your picture it can
seriously complicate their career or
even cause their dismissal we often
confuse our own transparency and work
as journalists and detectives
increasingly are losing their
opportunity to hide their sources of
information for example
should they use insecure messages and
opt-out of email encryption in my
opinion the answer is obvious those who
give up liberty for safety deserve
neither
a poignant quote from benjamin franklin
the founding father of america would
never have imagined that these words
spoken in the 18th century would be so
relevant in the digital reality of the
21st well
thanks for accompanying me on this
somewhat unsettling stroll through the
digital jungle
and definitely don't hide the fact that
you are watching sums up
check back in for more curious queries
suave suited brits and the information
that you need to survive it all
[Music]
freedom of speech doesn't have a lot of
meaning
if you can't have a quiet space a space
within yourself within your mind within
the community of your friends within
your home
to decide what it is that you actually
want to say
arguing that you don't care about
privacy because you have nothing to hide
is like arguing that you don't care
about free speech because you have
nothing to say
do you want a world
where companies can data mine your phone
they can get extract your data contact
all your details do you want a world for
instance where health insurance
companies will apply a higher premium
because you haven't done enough steps or
because you haven't logged in your
workouts or because you gained
four percent body fat equally essential
to what it means to be a free and
fulfilled human being is to have a place
that we can go and be free of the
judgmental eyes of other people
[Music]